EVERYONE GOOD MORNING.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH OUR
FIRST PRESENTER ITEM NUMBER.
ONE CENTER VALLEY.
A BILL RELATING TO ENERGY
BUILDING STANDARDS FOR WILL TAKE
REQUIREMENTS.
WELCOME.
THE CONTENT.
AND JUST FOR THE PUBLIC'S
BENEFIT FOR THE MEMBERS BENEFIT --
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THOSE ARE ITEMS
NUMBER TWO NUMBER FIVE AND
NUMBER.
SEVEN OF BILLS A. B..
FOUR EIGHT EIGHT AB EIGHT EIGHTY
AND AB -- TEN SEVENTEEN THE
MORNING WHEN YOU'RE READY THEN
ENTERS AND SHARED THANK YOU FOR
A BY IS TO PRESENT BILL.
AB -- ONE SEVENTY EIGHT SO LAST
YEAR WE BURNED -- THERE'S ABOUT
ONE AND A HALF MILLION ACRES WAS
BURNED IN CALIFORNIA AND I
HAPPEN TO REPRESENT IS CITIES OF
READING.
AND ALSO MIGUEL YOU WHICH WAS --
IS RIGHT NEXT TO PARADISE SO
ELEVEN THOUSAND MY CONSTITUENTS
IN -- BUTTE COUNTY WERE AFFECTED.
BY THE CAMPFIRE AND WE LOST
THOUSANDS OF STRUCTURES. EIGHTY
SEVEN LIVES IN THAT THAT FIRE
AND SO THIS BILL -- THERE'S A CC
MANDATE TO HAVE FORMAL TAKES ON
EVERY NEW CONSTRUCTION AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY SO THIS BILL
NARROWLY -- EXEMPTS THOSE WHO
DIDN'T HAVE INSURANCE -- TO AT
THAT DIDN'T HAVE THE VERBAL
TAKES ON THEIR HOMES AND SO THIS
BILL WOULD GIVE THEM AN
EXEMPTION UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND ALLOW
THEM TO REBUILD THEIR HOMES
EXACT SQUARE FOOTAGE -- IT
WITHOUT THAT MANDATE ON THEM SO --
THAT'S THIS THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES.
A VERY WELL.
DO WE HAVE ANY -- SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT YES GOOD MORNING JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE MEMBER COUNTIES CONTAIN MUCH
OF THE STATE'S FOREST LANDS AND
FOR A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
THE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES --
THOSE FIRES OFTEN HIT
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OR COMMUNITIES WITH
A LARGE PORTION OF THE
POPULATION THAT HAVE LOW INCOMES
OR ON FIXED INCOMES.
THIS NEW CC MANDATE WILL IMPACT
THOSE TENS OF THOUSANDS I THINK
IT WAS FIFTEEN THOUSAND
STRUCTURES FOR THE CAMPFIRE AND
FIVE THOUSAND FOR THE TUBS FIRE --
BUT THAT WON'T BE -- THAT
CONSTRUCTION WILL BEGIN UNTIL
AFTER -- TWENTY TWENTY THE CC
MANDATE WITHOUT ABOUT NINE TO
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS ONTHE COST
OF REBUILDING AND FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS EITHER WITHOUT
INSURANCE THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN -- BECAUSE OF THE COST
OF INSURANCE OR UNAVAILABILITY.
OR BECAUSE THEY WERE UNINSURED
UNDER INSURED THIS BILL WILL
HELP THEM BY REDUCING THE COST
FOR REBUILDING WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR KERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS KELLY COVERAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND WE'RE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IT IS SO VERY NARROWLY APPLIED
THAT IT REALLY WILL BENEFIT
THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE HAVING THE
TOUGHEST TIME REBUILDING THEIR
LIVES AFTER THIS DISASTER SO WE
ARE DRY VOTE THANK YOU --
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
AT A RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANKS [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
DO WE HAVE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. FORTY CHAIRED
MEMBERS.
MORE COMMONLY HAVE A SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
NARROWED THE BILL.
BUT THE BILL STILL FAILS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NOTABLE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SOME OF THE
UNCERTAINTIES REVOLVING AROUND
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AND
CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE NEED TO INCENTIVIZE AND HELP
HOMEOWNERS REBUILD USING
ELECTRICITY SOURCE THAT IS LESS
DEPENDENT ON A GRADE AND NO
LONGER RELIES ON A TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM THAT IS FAILING.
WHILE WE ARE SYMPATHETIC WITH
THE VICTIMS OF THE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES AND RECOGNIZE THE
FINANCIAL BURDEN OF REBUILDING.
WE ARE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
REBUILDING IN A WAY THAT WILL
INCREASE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
HELP REPAIRS SAVE MONEY ON THEIR
UTILITY BILLS WHILE ALSO KEEPING
CALIFORNIA ON TRACK TO MEET ITS
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
THE CURRENT FULLER REQUIREMENTS
ARE DESIGNED T SAVE MONEY AND
IMPROVE RESILIENCY FOR FIRE
VICTIMS.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THE COST CAN
BE INTIMIDATING BUT THERE ARE
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO FINANCE
SOLAR INSTALLATIONS.
THESE INCLUDE FULL FINANCING
OPTIONS SUCH AS SOLAR LEASING
AGREEMENTS AND POWER PURCHASE
AGREEMENTS FOR CUSTOMERS PAY
NOTHING UP FRONT.
AND SAVE MONEY FROM DAY ONE AS
THE UTILITY BILL SAVINGS
OUTWEIGH THE FINANCE PAYMENTS.
IN ADDITION TO CUSTOMER SAVINGS
ON BILLS THEY WILL HAVE ACCESS
TO THE RESILIENCY BENEFITS OF
ROOFTOP SOLAR.
POWER LINES ARE DOWN OR DE
ENERGIZED WHICH MAY BE
INCREASINGLY COMMON PARTICULARLY
IN FIRE PRONE AREAS.
EXEMPTING BUILDING CODE
REQUIREMENTS THAT REDUCE ENERGY
USE FROM THE GREAT AND LOWER
MONTHLY BILLS IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND CONSENT
ABOUT PRESIDENT.
CALIFORNIA HAS ADOPTED BUILDING
STANDARDS THAT WILL HELP REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
CALIFORNIA IS RECOGNIZED AS A
GLOBAL LEADER IN CLEAN ENERGY
FOR A REASON THE STATE HAS SET
TARGETS AND CREATED STANDARDS
THAT ARE CHALLENGING BUT
ULTIMATELY HELP CALIFORNIANS
PREPARE AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE STANDARDS
WERE DESIGNED TO SAVE HOMEOWNERS
MONEY AND PROVIDE A RESILIENT
ENERGY SOLUTION FOR AREAS AT
RISK OF WILDFIRES AND OTHER
DISASTERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO TAKE-THIS OPPORTUNITY TO STYLISH A
COURT CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HUESO.
PRESENT WITH A PRESIDENT MORE
LACK BRADFORD KING.
IN HERE DODD HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL HERE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO HERE SKINNER STERN.
TURN HERE STONE DOWN HERE WINNER
[inaudible]
WIENER PRESENT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OF WERE STILL TAKING TESTIMONY
SO -- WE HAVE A SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION THE RESTROOM.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OF ROTARY COMING UP OF SOMEONE
IN THE LAND FOR SOLAR CHOICE.
ALSO IN OPPOSITION REGRETTABLY --
WHILE THE AGREE WITH THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER THAT THE
OBJECTIVES ARE CERTAINLY
LAUDABLE OUR SYMPATHY GOES OUT.
TO THE VICTIMS OF FIRES HOWEVER --
PART OF THE THE CHALLENGE WITH
WITH THIS BILL IN WITH THE
ONGOING POLICY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
HOW DO WE MAKE THE GRID MORE
RESILIENT.
HOW DO WE PROTECT FAMILIES AND
HOMEOWNERS DURING FIRES WE
BELIEVE THAT'S THE PANELS AND
BATTERIES?
ARE ARE SIGNIFICANT IN A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE DISCUSSION
GOING FORWARD IN TERMS OF
RESILIENCY.
THANK YOU FOR THE PEOPLE OF
ENERGY AND LET OF FIRES AND THE
QUESTION I THINK THAT THE THE
COMMISSION CONSIDERS.
WHAT IN MORE TALKING ABOUT AREAS
THAT ARE ARE?
ARE PRONE AND SUBJECT TO FIRES
IN THE FUTURE [inaudible]
WHAT HAPPENS?
IF AND WHEN THE FIRE HAPPENED.
OCCURS LEADERS IN THE FUTURE.
A WE THINK THAT SOLAR PANELS AND
AND BATTERIES ARE SOLD FOR A
POTENTIAL SOLUTION AND CAN GIVE.
THESE HOMEOWNERS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES -- CONSISTENT OF
PROVISION OF ELECTRICITY SOME
REAL BILL POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
AS COUNSEL ALSO REGRETTABLY
OPPOSE WE APPRECIATE THE
NARROWING AMENDMENTS BUT ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE SUCH ABOUT
PRESIDENT.
OF PARTICULARLY AROUND COST
SAVINGS -- AND WE ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO RECONSIDER THANK YOU.
OKAY SO -- WILL HAVE A WILL COME
TO DISCUSSION NOW CENTER WIENER.
BUT I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN -- SO OF THE OTHER I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD I KNOW YOU
HAVE.
ONLY.
THE BEST OF INTENTIONS AND
TRYING -- TO DO EVERYTHING YOU
CAN TO FACILITATE RESULTING IN
YOUR DISTRICT I COMPLETELY
RESPECT THAT.
I'M JUST SO YOU KNOW WHERE I'M
COMING FROM LAST YEAR --
AUTHORED THE LEGISLATION AND SAN
FRANCISCO TO REQUIRE A SOLAR AND
I I SEE THIS COMMITTEE PASSED A
BILL I AUTHORED TWO YEARS AGO I
SEE -- SEVENTY ONE TO TAKE THAT
ARE REQUIREMENTS STATEWIDE WE
BACKED OFF ONCE THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WAS WORKING ON AND
THEY ULTIMATELY ADOPTED WHAT
THEY ADOPTED.
AND I HI.
I UNDERSTAND OF THE GOAL OF THIS
LEGISLATION I ALSO APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS -- BUT TO ME
FIRST OF ALL IT.
ON THE LEGISLATION AND PROMOTES
A NARRATIVE THAT I JUST.
DON'T AGREE WITH ABOUT
CLASSIFYING SOLAR AS AN EX AS
SOMETHING THAT MAKES HOUSING
MORE EXPENSIVE WHICH I DON'T
THINK -- IS ACCURATE -- ALL THE
THERE ARE YOU KNOW NOT ONLY ARE
THERE DIFFERENT WAYS OF ACTUALLY
GETTING SOLAR ON TO THE ROOF --
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HONOR YOURSELF
FOR EXAMPLE -- BUT OVER TIME OF
COURSE IT SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES
COSTS -- BY CONTRAST -- ENDLESS
EXPANSIONS OF THE GRID -- ARE
VERY COSTLY TO OUR HOMEOWNERS
INTO ANYONE IS PAYING.
A LECTURE BILL IN ADDITION THE
YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT THE THE
TRANSMISSION WIRES ARE HAVE BEEN
THE CAUSE.
OF A NUMBER OF THESE --
MAGNIFIERS I'M AND SO THAT YOU
WITH THESE FIRES HAVE POINTED TO
THE NEED. TO MOVE EVEN MORE
AGGRESSIVELY AND THE DIRECTION
OF DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES --
NOT LESS SO SO CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE DOING THIS
BUT I WILL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY [inaudible]
CENTER STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- SO
THERE ARE.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT -- SAVING MONEY IT'S
ABOUT SAVING LIVES -- AND THAT'S
WHAT.
OUR FOLKS HAVE BEEN THROUGH TOO
MANY TIMES AND THERE'S ALL
DIFFERENT KIDS OF PEOPLE WHO GO
THROUGH FIRES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I I APPRECIATE THAT.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE [inaudible]
VERY STE [inaudible]
SENSITIVE AND FOCUS CONVERSATION
OF PEOPLE LIVE BELOW MEDIAN
INCOME LEVELS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES SO I'M LOOKING AT LA
COUNTY BY THE WAY RIGHT NOW WE
WERE TALKING EARLIER --
550-005-5000 NINE HUNDRED NINE
DOLLARS SO.
THOSE FAMILIES IN THE WALLS THE
FIRE FALL OT.
AND I'M THINKING OF AREAS LIKE
CENTER RUBIO IS BEEN TO AND
SEMINAL SPRINGS AND THOSE ARE
THE TARGET POPULATIONS.
THE KEY THAT.
KEY POINT HERE FOR ME IS I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE'RE BUILDING THAT RESILIENCY
INTO THESE AREAS SO THAT THOSE
PEOPLE CAN BENEFIT. TO FROM
AGREED THAT WILL STAY ONLINE SO
FOR THE MEDICAL BASELINE
CUSTOMERS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT IN THIS COMMITTEE YOU KNOW
THE FOR THE PEOPLE ON
RESPIRATORS PEOPLE IN NURSING
ASSISTED FACILITIES -- FOLKS WHO
ARE IN POVERTY.
I'M I WAS SICK A RUNNING PICKUP
TRUCK LINES FOR THE DIESEL TO
GET THEM BACK ON LINE -- THAT
DOESN'T WORK IN A FIRE AND I
THINK SOLAR AND STORAGE OR MICRO
GRADES OR FUEL CELLS ARE OTHER
SMART DISTRIBUTED GENERATION IN
THESE COMMUNITIES IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR RURAL COUNTIES.
AND I DON'T KNOW OF THESE BILLS
THE RIGHT VENUE NECESSARILY DID.
TO TO GET US READY FOR PS PS FOR
REAL -- I KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT
SORT OF AN AND THERE WERE SLICE
OF THE QUESTION BUT I DON'T
THINK WE CAN BE NARAL RIGHT NOW
I GET YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE A
TITLE.
TWENTY FOUR ISSUE YOU SEE ISRAEL
AND A COST ISSUE AND I KNOW
THERE'S ACTUALLY SMART ECONOMICS
IS A ON GOING IT'S ACTUALLY
CHEAPER [inaudible]
BUT I I WOULD JUST WE WE'VE GOT
AS A LEGISLATURE I THINK THIS
YEAR HAVE THAT FIGURE
CONVERSATION BACKWARD RESILIENCY
SO I JUST. FOR RURAL COUNTIES OR
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE I MEAN.
DO YOU SEE A ROLE FOR TITLE
TWENTY FOUR OR SOME OTHER
MECHANISM.
TO THAT THESE CUSTOMERS JUST
LIKE THE FOLKS TO YOU KNOW HAVE
MORE INCOME ARE GOING TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT SAME BACK UP
POWER IN THAT SAME RESILIENCY
WHEN A DISASTERHIT.
BECAUSE I MEAN YOLO IS OFF LAST
WEEK AND SKY FOR WOOD SANTA
CLARITA AT OUT LAST WEEK -- IT'S
BAD SO I DO YOU MIND WHAT JUST.
WEIGHING IN ON IT WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING THERE.
ABSOLUTELY -- PROJECT QUESTION.
OR STOP -- YOU NEED TO KNOW THAT
THE THE DESIGN OF THIS BILL IS --
IT I WANT I WANT THOSE
CONSTITUENTS WHO HAVE THE MEANS.
TO BE ABLE TO PUT SOLAR IF THEY
CHOOSE RIGHT EVEN AND THEY HAVE
THIS MEANS IF THERE'S IF THEIR
CREDIT WORTHY ENOUGH TO BE ABLE.
TO FINANCE OUT INPUT CELERON
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
THEM.
THIS IS THIS IS FOCUSED AT FOLKS
WHO JUST WENT THROUGH IT AND HOW
TO DISASTER WHO.
ARE TRAUMATIZED FIRST OF ALL
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GO
THROUGH THE BUILDING PROCESS.
AND OVER THREE THEIR POOR PEOPLE.
SO THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO HELP
THOSE DOWNTRODDEN POOR PEOPLE IF
YOU HAVE THE MEANS AND THE WILL
AND THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
PUSH ALL ON BY ALL MEANS WE
WOULD WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THAT.
ALSO I AM ALL OF YOU KNOW
EXCITED ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S COMING OUT AND STE
BATTERY STORAGE I DON'T THINK
WERE.
WERE TOTALLY THERE YET ON I
THINK BUT THE TECHNOLOGY IS
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND BUT THAT'S THAT'S GONNA BE
SOME TIME OUT I'M TRYING TO
FOCUS ON HELPING THOSE.
PEOPLE THAT ARE BELOW THE MEDIAN
INCOME I WILL GET BACK IN THEIR
HOME THAT THEY JUST LOST AND IF
YOU KNEW THESE PEOPLE LOOK THEM
IN THE EYE AND AND THE
UNDERSTAND THE MOUNTAIN OF
THINGS THAT THEY ARE NEVER DEALT
WITH.
TRYING TO GET A PERMIT AND
TRYING TO REBUILD THEIR LIVES I
THINK YOU WOULD.
UNDERSTAND THE BILL FOR THIS
BILL I DO SO.
SO YEAH SO MY POINT IS IS THAT
LOOK.
IT IS MAY NOT BE A PERFECT BILL
IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEMS OF
THE GRID AND ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE HAD WE WE NEED TO DO I'LL BE
MORE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT.
WE ALSO IN SOME AREAS WE OVER
PRODUCE SOLAR IN IN IT WE ARE
ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE DOT CURVE
AND YOU KNOW MAYBE SOME PLACES
WE WE SHOULD MAYBE.
NOT LOOK AT SOLAR LOOK AT OTHER
ALTERNATIVES -- BECAUSE OF
PUTTING SOLAR THERE AND WE NEED
TO DO STORAGE IS THE I THINK THE
KEY HERE WE REALLY NEED TO FOCUS
ON STORAGE BUT THIS BILL IS NOT
FOCUS ON THIS THIS BILL IS
FOCUSED ON PEOPLE WHO JUST LOST.
LOVED ONES AND WHO ARE.
AT VERY LOW -- WAGE AND NEED TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL FOCUSED AT
NO I I KNOW THEM.
TOO I'VE BEEN TRYING TO HELP
TAKE THEM OUT OF THE MUCK MYSELF
AND AND MY BIG CONCERN IS THAT
THEIR PASSIVE IN THE
HOMEBUILDING PROCESS LIKE WHEN
YOU OWN A MOBILE HOME.
YOU DON'T GET A LOT OF SAY SO IN
WHAT THAT THING LOOKS LIKE
COMING BACK.
AND THAT DEVELOPERS NOT GOING TO
GIVE YOU A LOT OF OPTIONS SO
EVEN IF THEY COULD BUILD A
PACKAGE THAT LOOKED.
IDENTICAL TO LIKE WITH WITH SOME
BACK UP POWER MAYBE SOME SOLAR
MAYBE A BATTERY MAYBE SOME OTHER
RESOURCE AND WITHOUT.
THEY COULD ACTUALLY PROBABLY GET
YOU THAT HOME FOR THE SAME SAME
COSTS BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT THE DEVELOPER DOESN'T SO MY
CONCERN IS IF WE IF WERE.
STAY IF WE'RE SAYING FORGET
TITLE TWENTY FOUR THEN WE'RE
GONNA JUST TELL DEVELOPERS LIKE
YOU KNOW JUST THROW WHATEVER
JUST THROW IT BACK IN THERE AND
THEN THESE PEOPLE GOING TO BE
STUCK AGAIN.
THANK OSTER SO I'M A YOU KNOW
[inaudible]
I'M.
I'M I'M I'M I'M HUNG UP ON IT
AND I AND I I WANT I WANT TO SEE
YOU KEEP MOVING WITH THIS BILL
HERE BUT I WE'VE GOT TO WRESTLE
WITH THAT ISSUE AND I DON'T
THINK SOLAR'S THE PROBLEM I
THINK IS PART OF THE SOLUTION
HERE.
THANK YOU CENTER SIR CENTER BRAD
FOR FULL LISTENERS.
THANK YOU I I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR THIS MEASURE IT TO
COMMONSENSE MEASURE.
ALL WE TALK ABOUT THE FORD
ABILITY OF HOUSING ON A DAILY
BASIS IN THIS LEGISLATURE.
AND I'VE TALKED TO REALTORS AS
WELL AS I ATTENDED A HOMEOWNERS --
ASSOCIATION MINUTE MEETING LAST
THURSDAY MY DISTRICT
[inaudible]
AND THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE IN
SELLING NEW HOMES IS ADDITIONAL
CUTS AFFORDABILITY.
AND NOW THE DISH NO COST OF
ADDING SOLAR TO NEW CONSTRUCTION
ADDS THIRTY TO FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO NEW HOME CONSTRUCTION
ARI FOR FOLKS THAT CAN AFFORD
HOMES.
SO THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST
THEIR HOMES WE'VE HEARD TIME AND
TIME -- IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
FROM RESIDENT.
WHOSE BIGGEST CONCERN IS
REBUILDING AND ERRORS ARE WHERE
THE THEY LEFT BUILDING THE SAME
STRUCTURE AND THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO DO IT.
JUST WHAT OUT THE SOLAR AND NOW
YOU ADD THAT ADDITIONAL COST SO
THIS IS NOT ABOUT NOT BEING
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE IT'S
NOT ABOUT YOU KNOW.
NOT CARING ABOUT -- RENEWABLE
ENERGY THIS IS ABOUT ALLOWING
FOLKS TO GET BACK IN A HOME AT
AFFORDABLE RATES YOU TALK TO
REALTORS AND THIS IS THE HARDEST
HOME TO SAIL ON THE MARKET TODAY
IS HOMES WITH SOLAR.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE GROWN UP
CONVERSATIONS AND AND AND AND
AND AND LOOK AT WORK WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT PEOPLE NOT BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD A HOME.
THIS DOES NOT HELP FOLKS GET
BACK INTO THEIR HOMES WE SHOULD
HELP FOLKS WHATEVER MEANS
POSSIBLE TO GET BACK IN THEIR
HOMES YOU TALK THE BUILDING
ASSOCIATION.
THE MANDATORY SOLAR BILL HOUSE
COST.
HOME PRICES TO GO UP IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS NOT
MADE IT MORE AFFORDABLE WE HAVE
MORE FOLKS HOMES TODAY AND THIS
WILL ONLY OUT TO THE HOMES FROM.
CENTER STONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO STRONGLY
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH MY
GOOD FRIEND SENATOR BRADFORD
FROM LOS ANGELES WHO SPENT AS
LIFE -- DEALING WITH --
ELECTRICITY AND PROVIDING
UTILITIES WE WE HAVE -- ABOUT
THE HIGHEST MEDIAN HOME PRICE
PRACTICALLY IN THE COUNTRY AT
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- THIS IS JUST --
ANOTHER INSULT IF YOU WILL OF
THE PEOPLE THAT -- NEVER
EXPECTED TO WAKE UP ONE MORNING
AND NOT FIND THEIR HOUSE
STANDING -- THEY'RE STILL POST
TRAUMATIC SHOCK I WOULD BE IN
SHOCK IF I LOST MY HOUSE AND YOU
KNOW YOU YOU NEVER REALIZE --
THE THE VALUE OF YOUR INSURANCE
AND TELL YOU HAVE TO DEPEND ON
EXERCISING YOUR INSURANCE POLICY
AND A VERY IMPORTANT FACTOR IN
PREMIUMS IS.
REPLACEMENT COST A LOT OF PEOPLE
LOOK A REPLACEMENT COST WHEN
THEY WHEN THEY LOOK AT THEIR
FIRE INSURANCE I JUST WANT TO
LOOK AT THE LOWEST PREMIUM THEY
POSSIBLY CAN AND AND GETS ADDED
TO THEIR THEIR THEIR HOUSE
PAYMENT THEIR PROPERTY TAXES IF
THEY'RE IMPOUNDED.
AND THIS IS JUST A VERY NARROW
WINDOW THAT TO ME SHOWS THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE THAT HASGOT
SOME OF THE STRONGEST
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS OF ANY
STATE OF ALMOST ANY COUNTRY
PROBABLY IN THE WORLD -- WAS
SHOWING A LITTLE EMPATHY AND
COMPASSION FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE
LOST EVERYTHING [inaudible]
AND CERTAINLY THOSE THAT WANT TO
EXERCISE THE OPTION AND HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO PLACE THE COSTS OF SOLAR INTO
THEIR THEIR HOMES THAT IS STILL --
AN OPTION FOR THEM BUT THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GONNA BE
WAITING TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
YEARS BEFORE THEY EVER GET THEIR
HOMES REBUILT AGAIN AND THIS IS
JUST ONE OBSTACLE THE WE'RE
GONNA TAKE OUT OF THE WAY TO
TIME WE OVER GENERATE SOLAR.
ENERGY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDE FREE SOLAR --
ENERGY DERIVED -- ENERGY TO TWO
OTHER STATES BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT SOME PLACE -- SENATOR
CHRIS ALL WELCOME TO THE SENATE.
TWO THANK YOU FOR THIS AWFUL
BILL.
AND HI I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE IT
AND AND LET'S SHOW THAT WE HAVE
COMPASSION AND EMPATHY FOR THESE
CITIZENS OF LOST EVERYTHING.
SERRA RUPIAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT I WANT TO DISMISS YOU KNOW
MY COLLEAGUES -- MISTER WEINER
AND STERN I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE THAT
DIRECTION BUT I ALSO AGREE WITH
MISTER BRADFORD YOU KNOW WE COME
FROM SIMILAR COMMUNITIES AND WE
KNOW THAT WE'RE STRUGGLING TO
GET PEOPLE BACK IN HOMES JUST IN
GENERAL.
BUT THIS FOR ME AS A PARTICULAR
CASE AND PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING
TO REBUILD IT'S IN MY VIEW A
LITTLE BIT NARROWER.
AND I APPRECIATE SOME OF THE
MOMENT THAT YOU TOOK I THINK
THAT -- WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
COMPASSION AT THIS POINT WE WE
WANT TO HELP THESE PEOPLE TO GET
BACK INTO HOMES AND SO I DON'T
WANT TO BE DISMISSIVE OF
ANYBODY'S COMMENTS HERE BECAUSE
I THINK WE'LL HAVE VALID.
POINTS AND I THINK WE ALL CARE
VERY MCH ABOUT OUR ENVIRONMENT
AND ABOUT OUR COMMUNITIES.
BUT I CAN I THINK THIS IS JUST
GOING TO HELP THESE FOLKS BACK
INTO HOMES AND AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN AGAIN I THINK THIS
BILL IS ABOUT SHOWING COMPASSION
UNDERSTANDING HELPING PEOPLE
RESERVE -- REBUILD.
AND AND IN THAT REGARD I I I
SUPPORTED -- BUT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THIS BILL NOT SOLVING THE
ENTIRE PROBLEM.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT -- WHEN THE
ENERGY COMMISSION CAME OUT WITH
ITS MANDATE REQUIRING SOLAR AND
EVERY NEW HOME?
YOU KNOW I I I STRUGGLED WITH
THAT DECISION.
ON THE BASIS OF THE FACT THAT --
CURRENTLY OUR NAME RATES.
OUR OUR OUR CAN BE FOUR FIVE
TIMES HIGHER.
THEN -- PROCURING -- SOLAR.
FROM A SOLAR FARM.
EN EN WHEN YOU MAKE A DECISION
LIKE THAT REQUIRE AN ALL NEW
CONSTRUCTION HAVE SOLAR.
WHAT IS THAT GONNA DUE TO RATES
IN OUR STATE?
THEY MADE A DECISION.
INDEPENDENT OF THAT WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THE COST SHIFT IT'S
GOING TO TAKE PLACE.
AND THE IMBALANCE THAT IT'S
GOING TO CREATE ON THE DEPTH
CHART.
AND THOSE ARE THINGS THAT I
THINK NEED TO BE.
ARE DISCUSSED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE.
WE NEED A MAN ENSURE THAT THERE
ISN'T A COST SHIFT TAKING PLACE.
THAT'S GONNA AND SOLD.
WHAT WITH THIS BILL WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO GIVE?
UP POORER OR LET LOWER INCOME
HOMEOWNERS A REPRIEVE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME -- BY NOT
APPROVING THIS BILL WHAT WERE
PASSING COST -- TO OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE.
THAT ARE ARE ARE POOR IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT CAN AFFORD SO
LEARN I UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT
OF SO FAR WE'RE NOT GIVEN AWAY
SOLAR.
BUT EVEN IF WE DID.
IT ADDED IT IT IT RESULTS IN A
COST SHIFT IN RATES THAT'S A
THAT'S THAT CAN BE DETRIMENTAL
TO SPECIFIC PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO SOLAR.
OR OR OR CAN'T GET A FREE SOLAR
PANEL EVEN IF.
YOU SAY WELL IS THAT DOES IT
WON'T COST YOU ANYTHING I GUESS
THIS I GUESS PEOPLE THAT SAY IT
DOESN'T COST YOU IN ANYTHING
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT OF
GOING INTO DEBT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE CONCEPT
OF OF OF OF IN SOMETHING.
AND I'M HOW MUCH HOW MANY OF
THESE INVESTMENTS ARE GOING TO
BE PUT INTO OUR COMMUNITY.
THEY'RE ALSO GONNA RESULT IN AN
INCREASE LIABILITY TO THE TWO IF
THE BURNED AGAIN WE HAVE TO NOT
ONLY REPLACE THE HOME BUT THE
IMPROVEMENTS.
AND AT A TIME WHEN WE HAVE IT
ADDRESS THE LIABILITY ISSUE IN
THAT AT A TIME WE HAVE AN
ADDRESS THE BALANCING ISSUE.
AND A TIME THAT WE HAVE AN
ADDRESS TO COST YOU FIFTY ISSUE.
WE HAVE A A ALL ALL FULL OF
MANDATE I AM I HAVE.
ENORMOUS CONCERNS OF THAT I
THINK THIS BILL I DON'T WANT TO
THROW THIS BILL INTO THAT DEBATE.
BECAUSE I THINK IT SEPARATE THIS
IS A SEPARATE ISSUE.
ALL I'M SAYING IS THERE A LOT OF
THERE'S A LOT OF ISSUES TO
CONSIDER IN THIS BALANCE.
AND I THINK THIS BILL SHOULD
MOVE FORWARD I THINK IT'S A A
GOOD GESTURE.
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
SHOW SUPPORT. FOR THE PEOPLE.
IN OUR STATE THAT HAVE BEEN HIT
HARD HIT THAT OF LEST LOST
EVERYTHING.
AND WE'RE JUST SAYINGYOU HAVE
ONE LESS THING TO WORRY ABOUT.
AND LET US WORRY ABOUT.
FIGHTING YOU AFFORDABLE SAFE
[inaudible]
ELECTRICITY.
THROUGH THE OTHER MEANS THAT WE
HAVE BY FOR CARRYING IT AT A
CHEAPER RATE.
THROUGH OF THE LARGER
DEVELOPMENTS THAT COULD PROVOKE
PROVOKE PRODUCE SOLAR AT YOU FOR
RACHEL.
WE STILL ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I DON'T THINK THIS.
UNDOING THIS.
MAKES IT HARDER FOR THE STATE TO
ACHIEVE OUR OUR GOALS TO GET UP
TO A 100% WE CAN STILL PROCURE
CLEAN POWER FROM -- A VERY BROAD
AND DIVERSE SET OF OF REACH OF
OF OF SOURCES SO.
YOU KNOW I APPLAUD YOU FOR
LOOKING OUT FOR THE PEOPLE OF
YOUR COMMUNITY I KNOW YOU'RE
PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT I'VE.
SEEN YOU SITTING COMMITTEE.
ASK THE RIGHT QUESTIONS AND AND
AND TAKE THE THE THE MOST PROPER
COURSE OF ACTION TO REPRESENT
THE PEOPLE OF YOUR COMMUNITY AND
I APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND ASK THAT OUR COLLEAGUES.
SUPPORTED AS WELL.
OF WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE VOTE
NOW WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
STONE.
DO YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS [inaudible]
WHAT?
YOUR SUPPORT BUT I WOULD JUST
WANNA SAY -- SO I AS MANY KNOW I
JUST REALLY CARE ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT I'VE I'VE CHAMPIONED
ALL KINDS OF LEGISLATION. TO
TALK ABOUT THE MISSION OF
CARBONS AND WHERE THEY COME FROM
IN IN FORESTRY IN THOSE ISSUES
IN WATERSHEDS AND AND THIS IS A
NO BILL NYE I WOULD I SET FOR
MANY YEARS ON THE UTILITIES
COMMITTEE IN THE OTHER HOUSE AND
TALKED ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND
I'M I I'M.
AT THE TABLE WHEN YOU GUYS WANNA
TALK WHEN WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE OTHER ISSUES BUT THIS BILL.
IS REALLY NOW THIS IS THEY KNOW
A LOT OF THE FOLKS ALL TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOMETHING THAT I I'VE
TALKED TO THESE FOLKS THAT ARE
TRYING TO REBUILD.
A LOT OF AN EASY WHEN YOU DON'T
REBUILD YOU DON'T GET AS MUCH
FROM YOUR INSURANCE COMPANY IF
YOU'RE INSURED.
BUT IN MANY CASES THEY'RE TAKING
THAT MONEY AND THEY'RE GOING TO
ANOTHER STATE.
AND THEY'RE ABLE TO REBUILD
THEIR AND YOU KNOW I I GET IT
OPPOSED BY A LOT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT COMMUNITY ON MOST MY
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND IT IT'S
IT'S BAFFLING WE UNDERSTAND
SOMETIMES WHY.
BUT MAYBE THERE IS A GOAL TO ME
MOVE THE POOR PEOPLE OUT OF
CALIFORNIAN JUST KEEP THE RICH
AND WEALTHY PEOPLE HERE AND AND
YOU KNOW WE CAN HAVE A GOOD
CLEAN ENVIRONMENT WHICH OTHER
PEOPLE TO ANOTHER STATE.
AND I'LL SHARE WITH YOU WHEN YOU
LOOK IN THE FACES PEOPLE WHO
LOVE CALIFORNIAN WANT TO STAY
HERE -- THIS IS A TOOL THAT MAY
HELP THEM BE ABLE TO DO THAT
THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING FOR AND
AGAIN I WANT TO JUST RESPECT WE
SAY TO YOU -- ANYTIME WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THESE LARGER
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVEN'T AND I
WANT TO WORK ON STORAGE I THINK
THAT'S REALLY.
THE KEY IS STORAGETO OUR SYSTEM
TO WORK AND HEALTH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO YOU PASSED APPROPRIATIONS WAS
SO I WAS SO I MORE LOT MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHING CHANG AYE DODD
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
DOWN.
STONE AYE WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER NOW. SEVEN OF LOS -- WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS MOVE ON TO A WE WE HAVE --
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS ITEMS
TO FIVE AND SEVEN IF I CAN GET A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YEAH I'M A CONSENT CALENDAR AB
FOUR EIGHT EIGHT AB EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO AB TEN SEVENTEEN WEST SO.
I WAS SO I MORE LOT MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD.
CHANG.
CHANG I DODD HERTZBERG FIVE
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
DON'T STERN AYE STONE STONE AYE
WIENER [inaudible]
SIR [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHEN I MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO HERE? THREE SIXTY EIGHT
SOMEONE.
WE WILL NEXT [inaudible]
HISTORY.
SANTIAGO HAS TO THAT WHICH ONE
OF US HOW MANY ARE YOU.
HOW MANY OF YOU ARE THERE
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
THE MISTER.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ON AB -- FOR NINETY
SEVEN WHICH WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND
THE UP UC'S AUTHORITY -- TO
COLLECT THE SURCHARGE -- TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THE DEATH OF
DISABLED A TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROGRAM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER CHAIRMAN WILL KEEP
IT BRIEF IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
AND WE HAVE A WITNESS ALSO
TESTIFIED.
THANK YOU SIR.
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME'S ERIC HARRIS AND I'M
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA A NONPROFIT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVANCES AND
PROTECTS THE RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES.
WE SUPPORT A BEFORE.
NINETY SEVEN OVER FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
DISABILITY.
THAT INHIBIT THEIR ABILITY TO
USE TELEPHONE DUE TO DIFFICULT
SEEING HEARING SPEAKING MOVING
OR LEARNING.
OR SLASH REMEMBER. FOR FORTY
YEARS THE CALIFORNIA DEAF AND
DISABLED COMMUNITY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM HAS
PROVIDED CRITICAL EQUIPMENT AND
SERVICES. TO SUCH INDIVIDUALS IN
ORDER TO HELP THEM COMMUNICATE
WITH THE OUTSIDE WORLD.
THE PROGRAM IS OVERSEEN BY THE
CPC AND IS OMPOSED OF THREE
SEPARATE PROGRAMS.
IT INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA
TELEPHONE ACCESS PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES TELEPHONE EQUIPMENT. TO
QUALIFY PARTICIPANTS THE
CALIFORNIA REAP RELAY SERVICE.
WHICH ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO
COMMUNICATE BY DIALING 711- AND
THE SPEECH GENERATING.
DEVICES PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
HIGHLY INDIVIDUALIZED AND
COMPLEX COMMUNICATING SERVER
COMMUNICATING DEVICES THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH SPEECH TO
DISABILITIES.
THE R. C. IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT
A BEFORE.
NINETY SEVEN BECAUSE THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT THE CPC CAN CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE.
ON THESE CRITICAL SERVICES TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
WHO OTHERWISE MAY NOT HAVE THE
MEANS TO COMMUNICATE? TO MAKE
MEDICAL AND OTHER SAFETY --
IMPACTING CALLS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
ARE DR PLEASE SECURE.
ANYONE ELSE'S SPEAKING IN FAVOR
OR IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHAREEF ARENA.
I AM CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF AGENCIES FOR
SERVICES THE DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
I AM ONE OF THE ORIGINAL FOLKS
THAT WAS INVOLVED WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE DEAF TRUSTS.
THAT HASN'T BEEN LED TO THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE PROGRAM FOR
THE DEAF AND DISABLED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM.
SO YOUR SUPPORT MEANS A LOT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
GOOD MORNING THERESA ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARE CAN YOU SEE P.
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION AND
SUPPORT.
JANUARY TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NUMBERS ANYBODY IN THE DID YOU
WANNA.
DID YOU WANT ME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
SOMEONE SANTIAGO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
YOU KNOW I'M I'M ONE THAT --
USUALLY IS A VERY MUCH AN ANTI
TAX GUY -- BUT THIS IS AN
EXISTING TAX THAT I HAVE SEEN
HAVE TREMENDOUS BENEFICIAL --
AFFECTS AND IN MY COMMUNITY NOT
ONLY WITH MY CONSTITUENTS BUT
EVEN MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY -- WE
HAVE A REMARKABLE INCIDENTS OF
AUTISM NOW THEY SAY IT'S ONE IN
THIRTY FIVE NOW -- THESE ARE
FOLKS THAT -- ARE GOING TO HAVE
COGNITIVE DISABILITIES THAT ARE
GONNA BE NEEDING THIS TYPE OF A
SERVICE.
AND SO THE ONLY QUESTION AND I
REALLY HAVE FOR YOU IS IS WHY
WHY DO WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
SUNSET ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PROGRAM THESE.
COGNITIVE DIFFICULTIES ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE ON UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE HOPEFULLY IT WILL HAVE
SOME MEDICAL ADVANCES THAT WILL
MITIGATE THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
I DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING
ANYTIME IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
OR SEVEN YEARS IS THERE IS A
REASON WHY WE HAVE A SENSE AT
ALL A WE WERE JUST REQUEST TO
HAVE A CENTER THAT WAS NO OTHER
REASON I MEAN I I I WOULD AGREE.
SO -- NOT BY ME NO IDEA.
OF WHAT WAS AT A CONDITION OF
ANOTHER COMMITTEE OR YOU KNOW
WHAT LET LET ME DO THIS LET LET
ME -- LET ME GO BACK AND TALK.
TO PART OF ME TEARS AS HE
THERE'S ANYBODY TO CHANGE THAT
BUT I MEAN FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
YEAH YOU SHOULD BE AND I DON'T
KNOW IT'S ALSO FAIR TO SAY THAT.
IT'S ALSO FAIR TO SAY THAT THE
PC DOES NOT NEED.
TO AND I WANT TO SAY THIS FOR
THE RECORD I SHOULD SAID THIS
EARLIER THE PC DOES NOT HAVE TO
COLLECT UP TO THAT AMOUNT -- THE
POINT FIVE DAY COULD ALSO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT SO THERE'S SOME
FLEXIBILITY THERE AS WELL -- BUT
I THINK I THINK ALSO SOMETIMES A
THE SUNSETS ARE ARE DONE SO THAT
WE COULD TAKE A LOOK BACK AT A
PROGRAM -- IN IN RE VISIT THOSE
OF THOSE AMOUNTS OF DOLLARS AS
WELL THAT'S NOT MY INTENT BUT
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU A NUMBER OF
REASONS I FIGURED I WOULD BOTH
AGREE THAT -- THROUGHOUT THE
HISTORY OF THIS PROGRAM IT HAS
NOTHING BUT IN A BENEFICIAL
ACTORS BEEN NO CONTROVERSY
ABOUT THE SPENDING OF THE MONEY
HAS BEEN GOING TO THE
APPROPRIATE SOURCE.
I WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR
BRINGING A FORWARD BUT IF
THERE'S A WAY TO ELIMINATE THAT
I WOULD CERTAINLY -- APPRECIATE
THAT BUT I'M HAPPIEST PORTUGAL
TODAY IT'S CENTER MARLON.
YOUNG RESEARCHER -- MISTER
MISTER SANTIAGO MAYBE I'LL TAKE
IT FROM THE OTHER SIDE YOU KNOW
WHY EVEN.
WHY NOT HAVE A SUNSET WHY NOT
JUST GET IT OVER WITH -- AND
MAYBE ASK [inaudible]
HAS HASN'T.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
AND THE CPUC DEVELOPED ENOUGH
APPLICATIONS.
TEXTING OPPORTUNITIES FACETIME
OPPORTUNITIES. TO TO IN A SENSE
WORK ITSELF OUT [inaudible]
OR WHY WOULD WE NEED TO KEEP.
YOUR BABY TAKE THE OTHER SIDE OF
IT JUST SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY HONEST IMPORTANT
AGO MISTER CHAIRMAN.
YES AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR OF
THE BACK AND FORTH OF OF POLICY
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT I CAN APPRECIATE THAT.
HERE'S ONE THING.
WHEN I TOOK A LOOK AT SOME OF
THE TECHNOLOGY AND I TO THE TIME
TO GO SEE IT REVIEW IT AND YOU
LOOK AT HOW TECHNOLOGY HAS
CHANGED I MEAN WE WOULDN'T WANT
TO LIMIT -- WHAT WE THINK IS THE
BEST -- THE BEST EQUIPMENT NOW
WHEN SOMETHING BETTER CAN COME
DOWN THE FUTURE SO YOU WOULD
NEED TO CONTINUE TO COLLECT --
THOSE DOLLARS THE THE THE OTHER
QUOTE THE OTHER ISSUE TOO IS
THAT -- I HOPE IT'S NOT THE CASE
BUT WE KNOW THAT THAT
TRADITIONALLY IT HAS BEEN THAT
THE POPULATION WHO NEED THESE
SERVICES GROW GROWS -- AND SO
YOU WOULD WANT TO LIMIT IT
LIMITED BECAUSE FUTURE
GENERATIONS -- MAY NEED A BIGGER
POLE -- OF MONEY OR MAY NEED NEW
EQUIPMENT AND SO FORTH -- IT'S
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I SAY
THAT WE ACTUALLY MAY HAVE A MORE
THAN EATING NOW THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT A DIFFERENT SORTS OF
POPULATIONS WITH DIFFERENT SORTS
OF DISABILITIES AND OR NEEDS OR
CONDITIONS -- IT PAINS ME TO SAY
THAT AT SOME POINT IN TIME WE
WOULDN'T WANT TO LIMIT IT.
THE DATA A SUNSET A DAY IN NO
MORE MONIES DOWN THE LINE -- FOR
PROGRAM HAS HAD GREAT BENEFITS I
MET UP I'M PUSHING BACK ON YOU
FOR THE PURPOSES OF POLICY
ARGUMENTS.
SO DO YOU THINK THE CPUC HAS
BEEN DOING A GOOD JOB BEING
INNOVATIVE BEING.
COST EFFECTIVE EFFICIENT OR OR
HAS IT IS IT IS IT THE RIGHT
HOME FOR A PROGRAM LIKE THIS.
WHAT'S THE HOME THAT WITH THAT'S
THE HOME THAT EXIST IN NOW -- SO
WITH WE TOOK THE LENS OF LOOKING
AT WOULD TO WHERE THE PROGRAM
EXIST AND HOW TO CONTINUE THE
THIS -- VALUABLE SERVICE OFFER
INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED IT -- I
DON'T TAKE ANY OTHER LENDER MAY
BE HAPPY.
TO SIT DOWN AND GO BACK AND
FORTH BUT BUT AS OF AS THE BILL
CURRENTLY STANDS AND WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE IT -- CONTINUE MOVING IT
FORWARD THIS IS THE AUTHORITY
THAT CURRENTLY HAS HAS THE
PROGRAM SO IT'S WERE WERE.
LOOKING AT HOUSING THE PROGRAM.
IT REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS VOTE.
I BELIEVE SO YEAH THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU
ABSOLUTELY I ENJOY THE
CONVERSATION BACK FOR THE MISTER.
WE DIDN'T WANT TO DISAPPOINT YOU.
AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS.
OF THE OF CENTER STONE REGARDING.
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM
DEFICIENT SEE OF THIS PROGRAM
AND HOW IT'S BEEN WORKING.
SO WELL UNDER THE UC.
AND HOW OF OF ALL THE PROGRAMS
WE DO LOOK AT HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE IT'S THE ONE THAT HE
RECEIVED LAST.
COMPLAINTS ABOUT OR LESS
CONCERNED ABOUT SO SOMETHING IS
WORKING ON SOMETHING IS BEING
DONE WELL.
SO I WANT TO FLY YOU AND
CONTINUING.
WITH WITH -- THIS THE FOR
PUSHING THIS ISSUE.
ON BEHALF OF A COMMUNITY THAT --
NAY DESERVES ACCESS TO TWO OF
TELL OUR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE HAVE IN MOTION.
DID YOU WANT TO HAVE TO MAKE
SOME CLOSING COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE MISTER
TERM MEMBERS.
VERY WELL.
UP CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
APPROPRIATIONS WESO BY WAS SO I
AM OR NOT MOORLACH AYE BRADFORD
CHIANG.
DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
HILL -- HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
SKINNER.
STERN.
STONE.
STONE I A WINNER.
YOUR HONOR PERCENT ITEM.
FOR YES MISTER CHAIR -- I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF IF IT'S OKAY WITH YOU
YEAH THAT'S FINE AB FIVE TO SEE
IS A VERY SIMPLE BILL BASICALLY
WHAT IT SAYS IS RIGHT -- RAPIER
DOLLARS -- IN UTILITY SHOULD NOT
BE USED TO ADVOCATE FOR UNIONS
OR SUPPRESS UNIONS PLAIN AND
SIMPLEJUST DON'T BE INVOLVED
PERIOD OKAY.
PICTURE MEMBERS MIKE MONICA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES
IN THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LEXICAL WORKERS AS SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL.
MODEST COMMONSENSE WE AS FREE
ABOUT.
THANK YOU ARE YOU HAVE ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE PUBLIC LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR AN OPPOSITION.
MORE COMMON BE OFFICER CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
THIS IS A PROBLEM BERMAN BILL --
CENTER SOME YEAH JUST A QUICK
QUESTION HAS AS IT BEEN SOME
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES OF THIS ARE
HAPPENING IN THE PAST THAT --
HAS DISSIPATED THIS BILL.
ON AND I LOVE THE ON SPONSORED
WE DO KNOW OF SOME SOME ACTIVITY
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THOUGH IS.
THAT THE ATTEMPT IS BILLS TO
PRESERVE THE MAKE SURE THAT
REPAIR DOLLARS ARE NOT USED TO
THAT.
IN FAIRNESS -- I AFFAIRS CLOSED
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT -- INVESTOR
DOLLARS CAN BE USED TO PRIVATE
DOLLARS BUT AT LEAST WHEN IT
COMES TO YOUR YOUR HARDER MONEY
OR MY HARD EARNED MONEY. ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER NO MATTER HOW
DIFFERENT OR EQUALLY WE FEEL
ABOUT ABOUT -- UNION.
THERE'S BEEN AN EXAMPLE.
SICKNESS ESTATE OF THIS BILL.
WE WENT A BILL A COUPLE YEARS
AGO BY DUST WILLIAMS AND ADDRESS
THE SAME ISSUE -- BECAUSE THERE
WAS SOME ACTIVITY IN ONE OF THE
AYE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
USING REPAIR FUNDS -- AND WE
DIDN'T THINK IT WAS RIGHT THEY
DECIDE ONCE THEY SAW THE BILL
THAT WAS PROBABLY A GOOD IDEA TO
NOT DO IT ANYMORE.
WE PROBABLY SHOULD PUSH THAT
BILL THEN BUT WE WAITED AND WE
HAVE NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
MR HERE.
YES SIR IT IN THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND IN THAT EXPLAINED MY
QUESTION -- THE QUESTION I HAD
THE INFORMATION AS TO WHAT THE
MOTIVATION WAS WITH THE CONCERN
WAS WITH THE ISSUE FOR THE
PERHAPS.
UGH BECAUSE THIS IS WILL BE
COMING TO THE LABOR COMMITTEE
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT THE
BOOKS GOOD THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW I'LL TELL YOU WHY THIS
BILL IS IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH WHAT
THAT WORK WITH THE STATE -- AND
THE WILD FIRES.
EVER EVERY -- RATE PAYER DOLLARS
SCRUTINIZED AND AND HOUSE -- A
RE REASON WHY IT'S APPROVED --
MANY AND MANY CASES THE THE
UTILITIES MAKE A CASE THAT THEY
WANT MORE REPAIR FUNDS IN THE UC
TRIES.
TO BALANCE.
THE PUBLIC BENEFIT.
AND AND AND AND KEEPING RATES
LOW.
AND A LOT OF THESE UTILITIES
ARGUED THAT THE PC DOESN'T GIVE
THEM ENOUGH MONEY TO INVEST IN.
IN IN IN INFRASTRUCTURE IN -- TO
PREVENT IN -- FIRES.
AND SO WHEN WHEN THEY'RE USING
MONEY THAT WAS SPECIFICALLY
ALLOCATED.
TO RUN THE UTILITY TO MAKE
STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS AND CRANE
EFFICIENCIES AND AND SAFETIES.
AND THEN THEY'RE USING THAT
MONEY FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES IS
JUST NOT.
I I THINK IT'S A
MISAPPROPRIATION OF FUNDS AND I
THINK.
A BILL LIKE THIS NEEDS TO CALM
WHAT'S SIGNIFICANT SANCTIONS.
BECAUSE IT IS IS IT REALLY IS --
ABOUT USING MONEY THAT'S
INTENDED FOR ONE PURPOSE. FOR A
POLITICAL PURPOSE.
THAT IS -- DISINGENUOUS IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE IT'S NOT IN THE
PUBLIC FOR THE PUBLIC'S BENEFIT.
AND A IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
WAS AUTHORIZED.
BY BY THE P. YOU SEE.
ALSO THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL
AND I AND I URGE MY MY OF
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE FOR IT IT'S
HIS.
THIS IS ABOUT -- KEEPING PEOPLE --
ARE FOCUSED ON WHAT THEIR
MISSION IS TO PROVIDE A CHEAP
RELIABLE POWER SAY IN A SAFE
FASHION TO THE PEOPLE OF OUR
STATE.
OF ANYONE ELSE OF THE ONE MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK
MISTER CHAIR BY MEMBERS.
OF THE CLERK PLEASE CALL US WE
HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION CLERK PLEASE
CALL [inaudible]
THE ROLE.
DO YOU PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON LABOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RETIREMENT HUESO. FIVE HUESO AYE
MOORLACH BRADFORD KING.
KING AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HE'LL.
KILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN STONE.
NO NO WIENER.
NEEDS A COUPLE OF OKAY THROW
OPEN UP SOME MEMBERS IN THE
MEASURE [inaudible]
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARC MULLIN --
JERRY [inaudible]
JERRY.
CUTICLE WITH.
BILL.
WELL GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOLUNTEER -- WE'RE ON
ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY ELEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU MISS HELL MEMBERS.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO IMPLEMENT A TEXT AND
REAL TIME TAX THE NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE TO ALL COUNTIES BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REAL TIME TEXT
IS A TEXT TRANSMITTED INSTANTLY.
AS IT IS BEING TYPE TO
RECIPIENTS CAN IMMEDIATELY READ
THE MESSAGE WITHOUT WAITING.
THIS BILL WOULD BENEFIT THE DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING COMMUNITY BY
PROVIDING EQUAL ACCESS TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO TV WISE OR
VIDEO RELAY SERVICES.
IN CALIFORNIA TT WISE AND VIDEO
RELAY SERVICES ARE THE WAYS OF
COMMUNICATING WITH EMERGENCY
DISPATCHERS WHEN IN NEED OF HELP
FOR THE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING
COMMUNITY.
VIDEO RELAY SERVICES ARE
ACCESSIBLE THROUGH A THIRD PARTY
IT ALLOWS THE INTERPRETER TO SEE
THE CALLER BUT THE ACCESS TO
NINE ONE ONE IS SOMETIMES
DELAYED DUE TO TRANSLATION.
VERSUS A DIRECTX MESSAGE AS NEW
TECHNOLOGY KEEPS ADVANCING PT
WISE AND VIDEO RELAY SERVICES
ARE NOT THE MOST ACCESSIBLE FORM
OF COMMUNICATION WITHIN THE DEAF
OR HARD OF HEARING COMMUNITY
JUST LIKE PEOPLE IN GENERAL THEY
ARE RELYING ON INSTANT MESSAGNG
TEXT MESSAGING EMAIL.
OR VIDEO COMMUNICATION THROUGH
SMART PHONES OR COMPUTERS SAN
MATTEO IN SACRAMENTO ARE AMONG
THE COUNTIES THAT HAVE
IMPLEMENTED TAXES AND NINE ONE
ONE TECHNOLOGY ALLOWING.
ITS CITIZENS TO REACH AN
EMERGENCY DISPATCH WHEN IT'S ON
SAFE RUN FEASIBLE THE CALL.
IS TECHNOLOGY WOULD ALSO BE
HELPFUL OF THOSE WHO FIND
THEMSELVES IN SITUATIONS WHERE
MIGHT BE TOO DANGEROUS TO DOWN
NINE ON ONE SCENARIOS COULD
INCLUDE DOMESTIC ABUSE INCIDENTS
ACCIDENTS THAT CAUSE INABILITY
TO SPEAK OR ACTIVE SHOOTER
SITUATIONS AND WITH ME TODAY.
IS SHERRY FARINA CEO OF NOR CAL
SERVICES FOR DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO START WITH A
PERSONAL STORY TO SHARE WHAT
HAPPENED WITH MY SON. NINETEEN
NINETY ONE HE WAS JUMPING ON THE
BED.
AND HE ACCIDENTALLY FELL AND HIT
THE WINDOW SILL RIGHT IN HIS
FOREHEAD AND HE WAS BLEEDING
PROFUSELY.
SO AT THAT TIME THE TECHNOLOGY
WAS A T. T. Y. OLD ARCHAIC
MACHINES SO WE HAD TO GO OVER
THERE.
TAKE THE PHONE RECEIVER PUT IT
ON THE TT WHY CALL 911- I'M
HOLDING MY SON'S HEAD TO TRY AND
STOP THE BLEEDING IN EVERY TIME
I DIALED.
NINE ONE ONE L. A. P. D. WOULD
HANG UP THE PHONE.
ON ME.
SO I TRIED MULTIPLE TIMES TO GET
IN TOUCH HE DID NOT I WAS ABLE
TO I GRAB MY SON.
WENT TO THE CAR DROVE HIM TO THE
HOSPITAL.
HE GOT STITCHES HE HAD TO STAY
OVERNIGHT IBM OBSERVED FOR ANY
SORT OF CONCUSSION.
THE NEXT DAY.
I GOT HOME.
LAPD HAD RESPONDED TO MY CALL
FOUR HOURS LATER.
AND THEY HAD LEFT A BUSINESS
CARD.
ON MY FRONT DOOR.
SINCE THAT TIME I HAVE BEEN A
VERY STRONG ADVOCATE TO MAKE
SURE THAT ANY TYPE OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS USE.
IS ACCESSIBLE TO THE DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING COMMUNITY.
I SERVED LATER.
IN 200-011-22000 THIRTEEN ON THE
FCC EMERGENCY ACCESS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
THE P. A. A. C..
AND WE RECOMMENDED [inaudible]
AND PASSED.
A MANDATE THAT FCC WOULD ASK ALL.
STATE TO COMPLY AND RECEIVE.
TEXT TWO NINE ONE ONE SERVICES
FOR BOTH SMS TEXT IN REAL TIME.
THAT'S THE REASON FOR THE A
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL WE NEEDED
TO ADD THE LANGUAGE OF END FOR
SMS AND RTT BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE SMS YOU KNOW
THE REAL TIME TEXT [inaudible]
AND SO.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
STILL HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGY FOR ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO FORGOT TO MENTION.
THAT DURING THE TIME WHEN MY SON
GOT HURT AND I WAS ABLE TO
RECALL LAPD.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. FOR
THE US DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
TOOK MY KEYS AND AT THAT TIME.
JANET RENO.
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
SHE TOOK MY CASE.
AND PROSECUTED AND ORDERED ALL
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY CITIES OF
THAT AT THAT TIME TO COMPLY WITH.
THE TT WHY ACCESS.
TO NINE ONE ONE AND NOW.
WE NEED ACCESS NO MATTER WHAT.
LIKE SENATOR MULLIN SAID WE NEED
FASTER ACCESS WITH TEXT TO NINE
ONE ONE SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY.
OTHERS -- IN SUPPORT.
TODAY PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHARITY ACOSTA.
AND SEVEN YEARS AGO OF MY SON
AND MY HUSBAND WERE INVOLVED IN
A EXPLOSION A TRUCK EXPLOSION I
SAW EVERYTHING I COULD NOT CALL.
911- I HAD TO RUN TO NEXT DOOR
NEIGHBORS AND ASK THEM TO CALL
911-4 ME WRITING NOTES BACK AND
FORTH THAT REALLY DELAYED
GETTING SERVICES.
MEDICS ARRIVED.
AND IT WAS HORRIFIC AND WAS VERY
TRAUMATIZING I HAD NO WAY TO
COMMUNICATE.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CASEY PORTER
I'M WITH NOR CAL AND WHAT HAS
AFFECTED ME I WAS DRIVING TO
WORK ONE NIGHT AND THERE WAS A
WOMAN WITH A YOUNG CHILD WAS
INVOLVED IN AN ACCIDENT.
I CALL 911- IT WAS NOT ABLE TO
SEE THROUGH VIDEO.
AND SO TESTING WAS NOT AVAILABLE
AT THAT TIME SO I CALLED AND
SAID MY PHONE DOWN AND I WAS
HOPING THAT THEY WOULD TRACK MY
PHONE AND THEY DID TRACK MY
PHONE I MADE THAT CALL.
SO I WOULD IMAGINE IF I WOULD
HAVE HAD TAXED I WOULD NOT HAVE
HAD THAT WORRY AS TO WHETHER
DEBT CALL HAVE BEEN ANSWERED IF
ANYBODY WAS GOING TO RESPOND SO
I'M IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITH BURKE HEALTH SERVICES FOR
THE DEAF AS WELL.
I'M HARD OF HEARING AND I HAD
THESE TEXT TO NINE ONE ONE
BEFORE.
I WAS INVOLVED IN THE EMERGENCY
INCIDENT AND I WAS STANDING AND
WATCHING MANY HEARING PEOPLE
JUST.
WALKING AROUND TALKING TO EACH
OTHER AND JUST NOT DOING
ANYTHING.
SO I WAS GLAD THAT I COULD TAKE
ACTION ON MY OWN AND I SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS RACHEL AND I'M
HERE FROM SACRAMENTO I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE TECHNOLOGY WE NEED TO STAY
UP WITH THE ADVANCES IN
TECHNOLOGY. NINE ONE ONE CALLS
HAVE NEVER WORKED FOR US REALLY
SO TEXAN AND ONE IS IN.
CRITICAL BENEFIT FOR US FOR DEAF
PEOPLE AND FOR OTHERS IT MAY BE
EXPERIENCING A FIRE AND THEY'RE
ASKING FOR HELP AND NOT ABLE TO
USE OUR LAND LINE SO.
TEXAN NINE ONE WHAT WOULD HELP
THEM AS WELL AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
HELLO.
I'M KAMALA KAPPA AND I REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA LATINO X. DEATH
ADVOCATES.
AND WE SERVE THE ENTIRE CITY
CALIFORNIA ONE TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND THE AMENDMENTS.
SMS AND REAL TIME TEXTING THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MR TO MADDEN REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THEY GIVE MAD.
MORNING TRACY ANDERSON WITH THE
ARK IN UCP CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU -- IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT.
THE NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
READ IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY.
I I THINK THIS IS AN ISSUE AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
FOR BRINGING THIS.
IS VERY CRITICAL AND IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO US IT'S SOMETHING THAT.
I DON'T THINK HIM SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF ANY OF US REALIZED.
THE STRUGGLE IN THE DIFFICULTY.
IN ACCESS THE NINE ONE ONE
SERVICES.
AS WE HEARD TODAY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND SHARING THE
STORIES.
VERY POWERFUL AND IMPACTFUL
THANK YOU.
A CONVERSATION A YES THIS
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU.
I WANT TO ECHO THE THE REMARKS
OF FASTENER HILL IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE TAKE FOR GRANTED IT WE
DON'T EVEN CONSIDER -- JUST
GOING BACK TO ITS THE THE LADY
STORY THAT COULD A MENTAL.
YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
LIFE AND DEATH IN THAT
PARTICULAR MOMENT AND AND I
THINK WE NEED TO CATCH UP WITH
TECHNOLOGY SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT I
WILL BE SUPPORTING.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO SENATORS
DON'T THANK YOU DOUBLE DITTO --
PRECIADO ARE YOU BEING HERE
TODAY AND SHARING YOUR YOUR
STORY AND I'M LIKE THAT IT HAD A
HAPPY ENDING TO IT -- I WOULD
LIKE TO ACCOMPLISH FOR BRINGING
FORWARD TO SOME OF MULLIN LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF I
COULD AND ON WITH YOUR BILL.
WE THANK YOU -- WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBER OF
THE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR STONE --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO YOU PASS THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE.
WESSEL.
MORE LOT.
BRADFORD CHANGE CHANG I DIED.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL HI HILL
AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
REVIEW AYE SKINNER STERN.
STERN AYE STONE STONE AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
IT THE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
WILL MOVE NOW.
TO I REMEMBER SIX AB.
NINE TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WORKS GOOD GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS TO SEE.
THANK YOU I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AND THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS AND THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS. EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY THREE WOULD ALLOW
BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT OR BART
TO DIRECTLY ACCESS THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATORS OR CASO WHOLESALE
MARKET.
THIS ACCESSIBLE APART TO BOUNCE
A BINGE IT'S INTERMITTENT
RENEWABLE ELECTRIC SUPPLY
INCLUDING THE FORMER THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF ELECTRICITY IT
CONSUMES ANNUALLY TO PROVIDE
APPROXIMATELY.
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
PASSENGER RIDES. EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY THREE IS AN IMPORTANT
REGIONAL MEASURE FOR PART AND
THE MILLIONS OF BAY AREA
RESIDENTS WHO USE THE SYSTEM CAN
SAVE -- BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
ANNUALLY.
UP PRIMARILY ON THIRD PARTY
TRANSACTION COSTS I THINK THIS
IS JUST A SMART POLICY.
IT HAS RECEIVED THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT --
IN UNANIMOUSLY PASSED IN THE
COMMITTEE -- AND UNANIMOUSLY
PASSED ON THE FLOOR OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND AS A MENTION AS
PROVIDES NO STATE COSTS IN FACT
SAVES MONEY.
I WILL LET MY MY GUESTS HERE --
SELF INTRODUCED THEMSELVES AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
DISTRICT WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE TIME
AND ATTENTION ON THIS BILL AND
HAPPENING ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE -- DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER.
PUBLIC AND SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
ANYONE CENTER HILL.
DID YOU WANNA.
I WAS JUST GONNA SAY A FEW WORDS
ON BEHALF OF BARK GO AHEAD YEAH
SURE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M PAUL BOSTROM MANAGER
OF PARTS ENERGY DIVISION.
PARTS PUBLIC TRANSIT SYSTEM
PROVIDES EFFICIENT AND
AFFORDABLE TRANSPORTATION OVER
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND PASSENGERS
ON A TYPICAL WEEKDAY.
BART OFFERS A RELIABLE ALL
TURNED TO SINGLE PASSENGER
VEHICLES.
AND SERVICES IMPORTANT RESOURCE
REDUCE HIGHWAY CONGESTION
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AS WELL
AS ASSOCIATED FUEL CONSUMPTION.
AIR POLLUTION AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
THREE WOULD ALLOW BAR TO RELY ON
WHOLESALE MARKET ENERGY. TO
BALANCE IT'S INTERMITTENT
RENEWABLES SUPPLY ON AN HOURLY
BASIS.
INTEGRATING THE SUPPLY RELIABLY
FROM ECONOMICALLY INTO CHI SO
MARKETS.
THIS OPERATIONAL FLEXIBILITY
FLEXIBILITY IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT PART.
AS IT PREPARES TO BRING ONLINE
TO INTERMITTENT OUR PS ELIGIBLE
RENEWABLE RESOURCES. ONE SOLAR
PROJECT.
AND ONE NGUYEN PROJECT WHICH
TOGETHER WILL ACCOUNT FOR
APPROXIMATELY 90% OF THE
DISTRICT'S NEEDS BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS FOR
OFFERING THIS LEGISLATION.
AND ASK MEMBERS.
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU CENTER HEALTH
DID YOU WANNA GET COMFORTABLE
OPPOSITION THAT ARE I ASKED OF
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
IS ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE PROJECT
ANYONE.
THIS AREA THE G. WANNA SAY NO.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE THE BILL WE HAVE A
MOTION.
YOU MIGHT -- THANK YOU MISTER
THANK YOU BRING THE BILL FOR
JUST JEALOUS A LITTLE BIT SO.
DO WE HAVE ANY SENSE ABOUT THE
METRO.
I KNOW WE DEALT WITH THIS SORT
OF THEIR SIMILAR PROCUREMENT.
WE HAVE A WORLD IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO ANY I JUST WANT TO
SEE IF THERE IS ANY INSIGHT ON
COROLLARY PROCUREMENT
AUTHORITIES AMONG OTHER TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN THE STATE OF THIS IS
UNIQUE.
THIS IS UNIQUE. FOR KNOWLEDGE IT
IS UNIQUE -- YOU KNOW PART WAS
FIRST GRANTED THIS AUTHORITY IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE SO THIS IS
A PATH THAT WE'VE BEEN ON FOR
SOME TIME -- WHAT WHAT IS URGING
ABOUT THIS BILL NOW IS THAT --
MOST RECENTLY WHEN WE VISITED
THE LEGISLATURE -- TO GET ACCESS
TO OR BECAUSE I WHICH WILL
RESOURCES IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE THEN WENT OUT
AND SIGNED TO CONTRACTS WITH
THAT NEW AUTHORITY.
SO REALLY WE ARE HERE TODAY
ASKING FOR THIRTY SIMPLY
OPERATIONALIZE THOSE TWO
CONTRACTS MARKET.
OUR UNIQUE SENATOR STERN THE BAY
AREA.
THE QUESTION IS DOES ANYONE ELSE
IN THE COUNTRY TO THE OR EVEN IN
THE WORLD.
AS A TRANSIT AUTHORITY YEAH I I
YES.
DON'T KNOW THAT EITHER SO IT'S A
VERY INTERESTING THE WAY THAT IS
INVOLVED ANYWAY -- DID YOU WANNA
MAKE ANY CLOSE THE PROSPECT
CLASS FOR AN ITEM OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR HILL CLERK
PLEASE CALL.
THE VOTE. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL BY WAS SO
I'M MORE LACK BRADFORD CHIANG.
CHANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL.
FEEL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN STERN
AYE STONE.
STONE AYE WIENER.
HAS AND HAS ENOUGH VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OF PRESCRIPTION
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL THE TWO
WHICH WILL HELP CRACKDOWN ON
CALLER ID FRAUD AND SPAM CALLS.
AS FAR TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
KNOW THESE ABUSIVE PRACTICES
HAVE INCREASED DRAMATICALLY IN
RECENT YEARS AND POSE SERIOUS
RISKS TO CONSUMERS.
IN RECENT YEARS FRAUDSTERS HAVE
SOUGHT TO SPOOF THE PHONE
NUMBERS OF LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
SPOOFING A GOVERNMENT AGENCY
PHONE NUMBER CAN BE PARTICULARLY
HARMFUL TO LOW INCOME CONSUMERS
AND VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHO
MAY HAVE MORE REGULAR CONTACT
WITH.
AND RELIANCE UPON GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS AND OFFICES.
MALICIOUS CALL CALL SPOOFING
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES ALSO
UNDERMINE THE CREDIBILITY OF
STATE AGENCIES.
FACILITATE FRAUD BY EXPLOITING
STATE AUTHORITY AND REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD THE LEGITIMATE CALLS
FROM THOSE AGENCIES WILL BE
ANSWERED IN THE FUTURE WHEN THEY
COULD BE NEEDED TO INFORM
RESIDENTS OF EMERGENCIES OR
OTHER ESSENTIAL INFORMATION.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO WILL BUILD
UPON FEDERAL LAW TO HELP
INCREASE ENFORCEMENT STRENGTH
AND STATE LEVEL PENALTIES AND
AND THESE ABUSIVE PRACTICES.
THE BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
IS SUPPORTED BY THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS IT NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ
WITH THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
OUT.
THANK YOU CAN MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ARE NOT HERNANDEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA PROUD
TO BE A SPONSOR.
OF THE LEGISLATION -- AS THE
AUTHOR INDICATED THE CALLER ID
SPOOFING HAS BEEN ON THE RISE --
THE FEDERAL LEVEL BOTH REBEL
CALL THE NINETIES FIEND I TEND
TO BE NEAR THE TOP IF NOT AT THE
TOP.
OF THE LIST OF CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN RECEIVED IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS TRYING
TO CRACKDOWN ON THIS WE'VE BEEN
HERE ABOUT DEVELOPMENTS OF THE
LAST FEW WEEKS -- WITH A NOTICES
THERE HAS BEEN AN UP TICK
ESPECIALLY OVER THE LAST SIX TO
TWELVE MONTHS -- ON THESE CALLS --
INDICAN ARIZONA IT WAS UP TO
ABOUT SEVEN OR EIGHT MILLION
CALLS -- OVER LIKE A THREE WEEK
PERIOD THAT THEY STUDIED IT'S
BEEN ON AND ON THIS VERSION OF
COLOR ID SPOOFING IS
PARTICULARLY PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC -- BECAUSE THEY ARE
SPOON FEEDING AS THE AUTHOR
INDICATED A LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS SO FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAD A CONSUMER HEARING.
SACRAMENTO RECIEVE ON BACK TO
BACK DAYS A CALLER ID ON THEIR
HOME PHONE LANDLINE COOPER LAND
LINE -- DID THAT SAID CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AS WHERE THE CALL WAS
COMING FROM AND THEN ANOTHER ONE
THE NEXT DAY THAT SAID THE A
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AIRPORT --
IT'S BEEN ONGOING THERE'S ALSO
BEEN REPORTS THAT RANCHO CORDOVA
POLICE DEPARTMENT -- SAN DIEGO
SHERIFF -- IT'S BEEN ON AN ON
OFF FOR THESE PARTICULAR CALLS
IT WAS A BUSINESS -- THAT WAS
SELLING I THINK HOME WARRANTIES --
I THINK THERE WAS ANOTHER THE
SOLAR INSTALLATION SO THIS IS
BECOME -- A ONGOING PRACTICE OF
BUSINESSES AND SO THERE THIS IS
A WAY TO CRACK DOWN --
APPRECIATE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
AND PROJECT THE AUTHOR I TAKING
ON THIS BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
WELL -- DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
CAN YOU TEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
OKAY A MEMBERS ANYONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION DID YOU WANNA
MAKE ANY COMMENTS I DO JUST REAL
QUICKLY ONLY BECAUSE I WANT TO
PUT IT OUT THERE I MEAN I WAS
READY TO GIVE SOMEONE EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS NOT SO LONG AGO
A MONTH AGO AND I WAS TO ADD A
SEN.
AND I BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE WHEN
I CALLED BACK YOU KNOW IS ADD A
SENTENCE SO.
JUST PUTTING IT OUT THERE AND I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
YOU'RE DOING THIS TYPE OF WORK
BECAUSE I WAS VULNERABLE I
ALMOST.
GOT CAUGHT UNTIL THEY SAID THEY
NEED A CASH AND THEN I KNEW
SOMETHING WAS WRONG BUT BUT
AGAIN I I KNEW BETTER NOT
EVERYONE WILL STILL THINK YOU
AND I REALLY APPRECIATED AND I
WILL BE VOTING.
FOR I I I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS SENATOR AND WITHOUT.
JUST BECAUSE THE IDENTITIES OF
SAY THIS HAPPENED TO A MEMBER OF
MY FAMILY WHO -- WAS VERY
EMBARRASSED AFTER THE FACT AND
ALMOST ENDED UP TURNING MONEY
OVER TO A FOSTER.
AND I JUST WANNA INFORM YOU AND
LESS -- YOU ALREADY KNOW -- I
HAVE A BILL SB TWO OH EIGHT
WHICH IS -- A COMPANION TO THIS
BILL I THINK THEY WERE GOOD THEY
FIT CLOSELY TOGETHER THEY DON'T --
WORK AGAINST EACH OTHER IN FACT
THEY THEY THEY WORK WELL
TOGETHER AND TERMS WE LOOK AT
THE POLICY AND AND AND SEE THAT
THESE BILLS WOULD GO A LONG WAY
PROTECTING PEOPLE FROM SOME.
GOOFY.
AND I LOOK FORWARD.
TO MAKING IT TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR -- I I AGREE SENATOR I
THINK THE DAY -- THE BILL'S
COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER VERY
NICELY AS YOU'VE -- AS YOU
SUGGESTED AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
FOCUS ON THE ISSUE AS WELL THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO YOU PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WAS SO I WAS SO I MORE
LOT BRADFORD.
CHANG CHANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STERN AYE STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
THANK YOU.
THE BILL THAT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OF A FOR A JUMP MEMBERS.
AS MY FIRST.
WELL WE HAVE SIX WAS RIGHT
[inaudible]
SIX ONE SEVEN SEVEN PROBABLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME.
ON A. B..
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR THANK YOU TO
OUR WEST SO FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS -- AND FOR FINALIZING
THEM IT REALLY HELP THE BILL A
LOT WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
GOING TO BE FACING A LOT MORE DE
ENERGIZING A POWER LINES TO THE
WILD FIRE RISK.
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS TO
SHIFT -- A PERCENTAGE OF OUR S.
CHIP ARE URBAN -- SELF
GENERATION INCENTIVE PROGRAM
FUNDS.
BOB.
INTO A FUND THAT WOULD WORK ON
SOLAR PROJECTS TO HELP WITH
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN THESE
PARTICULAR AREAS SO 10% OF THE
S. CHIP FUNDS WOULD BE DEDICATED.
FOR RESILIENCY EFFORTS FOR AREAS
WHERE WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
DANTE ENERGIZING LINES FOR
THINGS LIKE FIRE STATIONS AND
SCHOOLS AND OTHER -- CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THE INS AND
CENTER FUNDS FROM THIS BILL
COULD SUPPORT MORE THAN TWENTY
FIVE LARGE FACILITIES LIKE WATER
SUPPLIERS AND WASTE WATER
AGENCIES HOSPITALS AND CAMPUSES.
AND THEN MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
SMALL FACILITIES SUCH AS SCHOOLS
AND FIRE STATIONS WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY AS A WITNESS IS JOHN
KENNEDY FROM THE ROLE COUNTIES
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I SHOULD MENTION THAT THIS
BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN JOHN KENNEDY
WITH RC RC WE ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF AB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR WE THINK THIS IS A
COMPONENT -- GOING TOWARDS WHAT
WE NEED TO IMPROVE THE
RESILIENCE AND RECOVERABILITY
AND THESE HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS --
WE'RE SEEING A LOT MORE DE
INTERNALIZATION EVENTS AND I
IMAGINE THAT WE'LL SEE MORE IN
THE NEAR FUTURE AND AND CONTINUE
IN FUTURE.
THIS IS ONE WAY TO HELP ENSURE
THAT OUR CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
HAS THE BACKUP POWER NECESSARY
TO AVOID -- SOME PRETTY NASTY
CONSEQUENCES -- BACK IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN D. ENERGIES
ATION EVENTS WE SAW A RISK OF
UNTREATED WASTEWATER POTENTIALLY
RUNNING OFF INTO STREAMS -- WE
HAD -- WATER TREATMENT PLANTS
THAT -- COULDN'T TREAT WATER AND
COULDN'T PROVIDE WATER SO BY
FOCUSING NARROWLY ON THESE --
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FACILITIES WE THINK IT IS A STEP
FORWARD -- WE DO SEE A NEED FOR
CONTINUED -- INVESTMENTS AND
MICRO GRIDS AND OTHER TYPES OF
STRATEGIES TO ENSURE THAT --
THESE COMMUNITIES WILL HAVE
POWER AND THAT PEOPLE WILL NOT
JUST THE LINGERING FOR DAYS AT A
TIME WITHOUT POWER AND WITHOUT
THE ABILITY TO PUMP WATER FROM
THE GROUND FOR BATHING FOR
SANITATION PURPOSES FOR ANYTHING --
SO WITHOUT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT YOU
ARE ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YES I AM OKAY.
FUNDED ARE DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS.
ON THIS MEASURE -- SUPPORT
RIPOSTE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MANUALLY ON
BEHALF OF TESLA WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE STILL ARE
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS BUT WE
DO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT THAT
WOULD -- ADDRESS ONE OF OUR KEY
CONCERNS WHICH IS TO GIVE THE PC
DIRECTION UPDATES RULES IN ORDER
TO ACCOMPLISH.
THE BILL'S OBJECTIVE -- HOWEVER
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE OTHER
AMENDMENT THAT -- THAT WOULD
HOLD AN APPLICANT ACCOUNTABLE
FOR A COMMUNITIES ACTION TO
ADDRESS WILDFIRE RISK EVEN IF
THE APPLICANT HASNO CONTROL OF
POWER TO INFLUENCE A COMMUNITY'S.
ACTIONS IN THIS REGARD AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR ON THIS
CONCERN THANK YOU OKAY --
MEMBERS TO HAVE ANYTHING
[inaudible]
CENTER START.
YEAH THANKS -- CAN CAN WE GET A
LITTLE MORE CLARITY ON THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE WHAT WHAT THE
THE FEED YOUR RECORDED IN FEET
POWER BACK TO THE GREAT IF
YOU'RE SURE TO CALL THE POINTS
LIKE A DEMAND RESPONSE KIND OF
FRAMEWORK -- HASN'T EXPLAINED
YEAH YOU COULD.
SURE SENATOR -- AYE AYE ACTUALLY
THIS IS VERY MUCH IN LINE WITH
YOUR SB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR ROUTE
PLANNING.
AND SO THE IDEA WOULD BE TO
INSURE THAT BECAUSE IT IS
LIMITED FUNDING AND IT'S ONLY
FOR ONE YEAR.
AND THERE ARE MANY OF FACILITIES
THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE HERE THAT
WE SHOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT THOSE
FACILITIES ARE PRETTY WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY AND THE BLACK
COMMUNITY ITSELF SHOULD ALSO.
IF WE WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY
TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
COORDINATING AND PLANNING ALONG
WITH SOME OF THE REQUIREMENTS
AND SEVEN SEVEN FOUR AROUND THE
WALL FOR MEDICATION PLANS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLARIFICATION
AND TO MISTER CANYON RC RC AND
AND TO THE AUTHOR.
I THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PUZZLE WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO SORT
OUT WITH.
AS SENATOR DOLLY IS WELL AND IS
IT A BIGGER PUSH ON NOT LEAVE
OUR COMMITTEES POWERLESS.
IN THESE SO MY CONCERN IS.
YOU SAID A HUNDRED SMALL AND
TWENTY FIVE BIG.
FROM MY CONVERSATION A CALLOW
YES WE'RE IN THE THOUSANDS AT
LEAST.
GIVE A SENSE DO WE HAVE A SENSE
OF SCALE HERE LIKE IN TERMS OF
VULNERABILITY EVEN FOR THIS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE DO WE
YET KNOW THE SIZE OF THE PROBLEM.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE MORE FUNDING
INTO THIS PROGRAM AND CERTAINLY
GOING INTO THE FUTURE I MEAN
THERE'S NOTHING THAT WOULD
PREVENT SOME OF THE ESTATE MONEY
FROM BEING USED THIS IS AND THIS
IS A GUARANTEED AT LEAST 10% OF
IT WILL GO TOWARDS IS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE'S NOTHING.
TO PREVENT MORE OF IT FROM GOING
TOWARDS THAT BUT I THINK IF THE
COMMENT IS THAT WE COULD USE
MORE RESOURCES TO GO INTO THESE
AREAS I COMPLETELY AGREE YEAH.
AND I GUESS MY THE CHALLENGES I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE I GUESS YOU
HAS A UNIQUE FUNCTION WITHIN THE
INCENTIVE STRUCTURE RIGHT SO WE
DON'T WANT.
TO TAKE THAT ENTIRE POT WHICH
WAS DESIGNED FOR ONESELF
GENERATION TYPE AND THEN.
TRY TO SOLVE THIS RESILIENCY
PROBLEM WRIT LARGE WITH IT SO I
THINK WE'RE JUST GONNA HAVE TO
GET CREATIVE ABOUT IT WE HAVE TO
PUSH THE COUNTY'S.
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO STAR
CORNING WITH PC SEPARATE SHE THE
EFFORT I'D LOVE TO BE -- ADDED
ON AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
MOVE THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME.
WELL THAT'S YEAH I MEAN IF I GET
ANYTHING SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET FROM THE
GENERAL FUND FOR BACKUP POWER
FOR THE STATE IS NOT SUFFICIENT.
WE'RE GONNA BACK UP MAYBE THIRTY
CAL FIRE FACILITIES WITH A
FUNDING IN THE IN THIS THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THAT'S JUST CAL
FIRE FACILITIES YOU'RE GONNA
MAYBE COVER A HUNDRED WE GOT
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS WE'VE GOT TO SOLVE
THIS RIGHT NOW IS PART OF THE
FIRE PACKAGE.
WE SHOULD NOT BE WILLING TO FIRE
PACKAGES LEGISLATURE WITHOUT
RESILIENCY PLAN FOR NURSING
ASSISTED FACILITIES AND YOU KNOW
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON MEDICAL BASS
LINE.
GOT US ALL OF OUR THAT'S A
GOVERNMENT SOAPBOX THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT VERY WELL THANK YOU --
DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND WOULD BE VERY PROUD
TO ADD YOU AS A CO AUTHOR WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH YOU IN WITH THE CHAIR ON
THESE ISSUES -- THROUGHOUT THE
INTERMINGLING TO NEXT YEAR OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU.
OF TO HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
WORK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WHAT'S
SO I WAS SO I MORE LACK BRADFORD.
CHAIN.
GANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STERN AYE STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
THANK YOU ALL.
WE HAVE ENOUGH VOTES WILL PLAY.
THE ROLE OF WRAPS AND MEMBERS WE
HAVE OUR NEXT OFF THE RADIO
PERCENT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TOO OFTEN GOOD
MORNING NO YOU DON.
ARE YOU.
HAVING A FANTASTIC DAY THANK YOU
ACCESS OR TO HOPE WE CAN MAKE IT
BETTER.
A LOT OF TODAY.
I WILL BE AS BRIEF AS I CAN OKAY
THANK YOU AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE
AT YOUR PLEASURE THANK YOU LET
ME FIRST START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH NEAR
THE BILL TO DISTRICTS THAT ARE
TRULY IN TROUBLE I WANT TO FIRST
THANK YOUR STAFF -- YOUR
CONSULTANT FOR WORKING SO CLOSE
WITH MY TEAM AND OUR SPONSORS TO
WORK OUT THE LANGUAGE.
THIS IS COMMITTEE THE KNOWS FULL
WELL HOW UNACCEPTABLE IS THAT IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE STILL
HAVE COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE
REPRESENTING OVER MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO LACK ACCESS TO
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
WITH WATER DISTRICTS --
OFTENTIMES HAVING SO MUCH
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IF THEY'RE
ON THE VERGE OF CONTAMINATION.
MANY OF THESE SYSTEMS CAN AFFORD
TO MAKE NECESSARY IMPROVEMENTS
BUT ARE NEAR LARGER WATER
DISTRICTS THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE
CONSOLIDATION.
CONSOLIDATION WATER SYSTEMS CAN
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS IN
NEARBY AREAS RECEIVE CLEAN WATER
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE APPROVAL
PROCESS CAN OFTEN BE VERY TIME
CONSUMING.
THE CPC HAS AN OBLIGATION REVIEW
PROPOSED CONSOLIDATIONS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY -- WE'VE SEEN VERY
LONG TIME FRAMES AND WE KNOW THE
LONGER REVIEW TAKES A LONGER
CALIFORNIANS ARE LEFT WITH.
UNSAFE DRINKING WATER WE NEED TO
PROTECT BOTH EXISTING REPAIRS
AND DELIVER CLEAN WATER TO NEW
CUSTOMERS THIS BILL WOULD IMPOSE
FLEXIBLE DEADLINES ON THE SI PC
FROM ITS AUDITION APPROVAL.
AND ENSURE THAT THE AGENCY HELP
TO IMPLEMENT OUR STATES POLICIES
TO PROVIDE WATER TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE SYS REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION AND I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU JACK WALKS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION -- IT DOES ONE ECHO
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO HAS JUST
SAID -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK -- YOU -- CHAIR HUESO AND
YOUR STAFF -- FOR THE AMENDMENTS
TODAY -- THE LAST NIGHT.
AND THIS IN PART THIS WE HAVE A
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM HERE AT THE
COMMISSION BUT WE ALSO HAVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY WITH THE PASSAGE
OF THIS BILL TO WORK OUT A MORE
EXPEDITED STREAMLINED APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR CONSOLIDATIONS THEY
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A STARTING
POINT IT EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND
THEN GO FROM THERE.
AND THIS -- WIDE BY A RESETTING
THE CLOCK HERE -- WITH THE BUT
STILL PROVIDING THE P. UC WITH
PLENTY FLEXIBILITY AND AND
EXTENSIONS IF NECESSARY -- WE
WILL BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH
THESE -- CONSOLIDATIONS -- MORE
QUICKLY THAN HAS BEEN THE CASE
TODAY.
AND FOR THAT -- SO YEAH I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVAN JACOBS -- I AM
DIRECTOR REGULATORY POLICY
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN WATER AND
VICE PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS SPONSORING.
AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE AS SOME OF
YOU MAY BE AWARE CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN WATERS THAN A LOT OF
WORK ON CONSOLIDATING SMALL
TROUBLED WATER SYSTEMS AND I I
THINK WE'VE REALLY LED THE STATE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
WE'VE CONSOLIDATED SEVEN SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS. SIX OF WOULD
SERVE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE FIVE MORE CONSOLIDATIONS
THAT ARE PENDING EITHER YET TO
BE FILED AT THE PC OR FILED
WORKING ITS WAY THROUGH.
IT SEVERAL OF THESE APPLICATIONS
OF TAKING MORE THAN A YEAR AT
THE P. UC.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE PROCESS
CAN BE MORE EFFICIENT IN THE
BOTH THE WATER UTILITIES AS WELL
AS PC STAFF AND REGULATORS CAN
DO MORE TO PROCESS THESE AN
EXPEDITE THESE TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING SAFE CLEAN WATER.
TO OUR CUSTOMERS AND HELP ENSURE
THE HUMAN RIGHTS WATER IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS WE WORK ON THE STAFF
I THINK THOSE ARE GOOD.
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS LEGISLATION
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- DO WE HAVE ANY SPEAKERS
IN THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. FOR COMMON BE ALPHA SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION.
THE ONE OUR MEMBERS. TWO OF THE
MOTION.
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A MOTION.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO YOU PASS IS AMENDED TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY WAS SO
HIGH.
WITH SO I MOORLACH BRADFORD KING
CHIANG AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HILL AYE
MCGUIRE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
OKAY HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF CORRUPTION
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU MISTER
TRAFFIC ENTERS THANK YOU --
WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH THE ROLE
FOR THE MEMBERS THAT ARE PRESENT
SO WE CAN -- DISPATCH YOU.
HERE.
YOUR NEXT DUTIES -- STARTING
WITH ITEM NUMBER.
ONE WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- WILL BEGIN WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT'S ITEMS
TWO SEVEN AND FIVE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OR CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
M. CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
PHONE NINE ZERO BRADFORD.
DODD.
DODD AYE MCGUIRE SKINNER.
WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AB.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
EIGHT ONE DODD.
DODD AYE MCGUIRE SKINNER STERN.
WELL HELLO.
THE ROLE OF THE CORRUPTION
MEMBERS WILL GO TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB.
FOR NINETY SEVEN OUR CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO BRADFORD.
CHIANG.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE
RUBIO.
RUBIO ICE SKINNER STERN WIENER.
WILL MOVE DILIGENTLY TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. B..
FIVE SIXTY CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
DO YOU PASSED THE LABOR AND
PUBLIC EMPLACEMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE.
THE CURRENT VOTE.
FIVE ONE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD.
NUMBER FOUR SANTIAGO.
BRADFORD AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE.
SKINNER STERN.
STONE.
SORRY JONES NOW WIENER.
RIGHT WIENER AYE.
WILL MOVE NOW TO ITEM NUMBER SIX
A. B..
NINE TWENTY THREE THE BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT.
THE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN ZERO MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
MCGUIRE SKINNER.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB.
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO OF THE CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
DO YOU PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
ZERO MORE A LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE SKINNER
WIENER.
WIENER HI.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
QUICK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THE PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN ZERO MORE A LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE SKINNER
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. ELEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
DO YOU PASSED TO THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO
HUESO AYE HUESO AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE MCGUIRE SKINNER.
WIENER WIENER HI.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
QUIRK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GIVE PASSES AMENDED TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO MORE A
LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE MCGUIRE.
SKINNER STERN.
WIENER.
WIENER HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGAIN ON LOVE ITEM [inaudible]
ELEVEN MCGUIRE [inaudible]
JENNER STERN.
WE'LL GO [inaudible]
TO SKINNER AYE.
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER WHAT OTHER.
WILL TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ONE MORE TIME.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE MCGUIRE.
SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER AYE.
WHAT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN?
WORLD OF MOVED ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE PASTOR
PREPARATIONS CURRENT PHONE NINE
ONE MCGUIRE SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB FOR NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE PASTOR
PREPARATIONS CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
ZERO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I AGING.
MCGUIRE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN.
WE DON'T NUMBER THREE AB FOR
NINETY SEVEN BY.
STERN STERN AYE WIENER WIENER
AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB FIVE SIXTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
QUIRK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO PASS A LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO MCGUIRE
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN -- STERN AYE
[inaudible]
MCGUIRE AYE [inaudible]
YEAH YES.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B..
LINE TWENTY THREE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB NINE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
I HAD TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE.
WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT A A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
DO YOU PASSED TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
YES HI SKINNER I THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER.
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
A. B. ELEVEN FORTY FOUR CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
LEVIN ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I THE BILL IS OUT WILL
CLOSE ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB ELEVEN SIXTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN.
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO PASS A GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE NUMBER
ELEVEN ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE.
ITEM NUMBER EEVEN AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE PASSES
AMENITY ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE CURRENT ELEVEN ZERO
MCGUIRE.
WHERE I A SKIN ARE STERN?
STERN I THE BILL IS THAT WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE WILL COME BACK TO
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND ITEMS TO FIVE AND SEVEN
CLEAR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MCGUIRE AYE.
WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE AB ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS%
CURRENT VOTE NINE ONE MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
WELL CLOSER ROLE THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB FOR NINETY
SOME BY SIMPLY WERE SANTIAGO
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THE PASTOR FOR CREATIONS
CURRENT A LEVIN ZERO CHIANG
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MCGUIRE AYE.
THE BILL IS DOUBLE CLOSER ROLE --
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB FIVE SIXTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO THAT
BILL.
HE IS OUT WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND AND WILL CLOSE ROLE ON ALL
REMAINING BILLS THAT WE HAVE A
CLOSE ROLE.
AND WE WILL NOW OFFICIALLY
ADJOURNED THE MEETING THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY